it's a privilege to be here and even
more of an honor to be here with two GSB
alums partners of mine and I want to
offer you some career advice and tell
you the story of kleiner perkins and be
sure that trade Vassallo to your left my
partner since 2000 and in GSB grad can
share with you her perspective on
innovation entrepreneurs and venture
capital and also Chiwa Chen a grad of
2006 is that right and I'll have more to
say about both of them in just a second
give the clicker
I prepared 14 slides and my goal for
this time is to spend over half of it in
QA in interaction with you so as we go
along
I'll pull out your notebook write down
questions we're going to try to cover as
many of those as we can collectively my
'man the first part of our conversation
is to tell you a little bit about
kleiner perkins our business our
strategy to tell you a little bit about
what's going on in two of the three
initiatives that we think are really
important go into green technologies and
digital technologies and then to offer
you some unsolicited career advice as
you're thinking about where you're going
with your career and perhaps even your
life that's worth what you're gonna pay
for it which is nothing and and and then
and then we'll dive right into questions
and answers and I hope hope that'll do
well we will end on time in an hour
so the kleiner perkins partnership is a
service business we're in a service
industry our business doesn't scale very
well our job is to help entrepreneurs
and the way we've figured out to best do
that is to build our team of partners
with people who have had significant
entrepreneurial experience so tre was a
early founder of the company that today
is really the core of palm computing she
designed the palm 5 which is the iconic
PDA chi-wah he worked at a very hot you
know advertising networking company
built ad networks and then we ripped him
out of Excel partners to come take on a
lot more response
ability here at Kleiner that ability to
connect with and serve entrepreneurs is
key to being good in the venture capital
business and we've done a good job we've
got a couple hundred years of investing
experience in our partnership we view
ourselves more as company builders than
financiers Iran more discounted cash
flow statements at Intel than I ever
have done since I've come to kleiner and
and the heart I think of what we have to
offer is our team this is a 16 of our
investing professionals that's the whole
team working on digital technologies and
green technologies we have some other
partners who work in the life sciences
and of course you'll seed tray and
you'll see chi-wah their kleiner has
always had a strategy of being a
multi-generational partnership so that
anytime there's three generations of
partners in our firm a venture capital
firm could be an episodic collection
that talented individuals unfortunately
one when I joined in 1980 as an
untalented individual Tom Perkins who
had built kill at Packard said we want
to build a service organization that can
last that can last beyond any other
partners so everybody I should point out
here tray and chi-wah that's Al Gore
stands out I guess a lot of venture
firms have people that are door openers
and their names on the nameplate and so
forth al is not that he's an amazing
leader in human being I mean we came so
close within 400 votes in Florida of
having him be present in the United
States or one vote in the Supreme Court
we'd be in a much better world today if
that were the case but al al is this al
al is a nerd he's a techie he's on email
he responds all the time any time he's
in the Bay Area which is often several
times a month that he comes to the
offices he comes to the partner meetings
it comes to the strategy off sites and
he gives us great investing insights I
hope in your work in these fields that
you'll get to know Al Gore thank you
that's the track record those are the
results a lot of jobs a lot of
investments a lot of IPOs and a lot of
market value we work for the Stanford
endowment and other university
endowments
they give us part of the endowment our
job is to return to them ten times more
what what they give us and we've done
that pretty successfully over about a
decade we distributed a billion dollars
of profits a year to our limited
partners on average it's been tougher
now for public offerings and for
distributions and returns but that just
means we got to work harder and the
entrepreneurs have got to be more
successful our strategy is to focus on
building companies and helping the
entrepreneurs at the world build
companies that can take many different
forms in the in the case of Google it
took the form of helping them get a
great CEO and then work on their
strategies in the case of some of the
companies that she was working on it
takes the form of forging strategic
relationships and going after the right
markets if you do all that well the one
final ingredient that makes for a really
great company is the culture of the
company what are their values because I
believe that you'll in the next year or
two be looking at where you launch your
career I want to share with you an
observation that Randy Komisar made
about companies and their values and he
said you know there's there's two really
different strains if you want to paint
the extreme in Silicon Valley companies
and either one can succeed in fact we
see both of them succeeding but I think
if you go into your first assignment if
you when you're interviewing have this
in mind it I think can help you make
better choices about what works for you
and and and I refer to these strains as
the mercenaries and the missionaries the
mercenaries and the missionaries right
in a mercenary culture there's
tremendous Drive and in fact Andy Grove
even said only the paranoid survive in a
missionary culture by contrast there's
passion Drive and passion think about
the difference of those two in the
mercenary culture I like to say that the
entrepreneurs the executives are
opportunistic the missionaries are more
strategic the mercenaries focus on the
pitch on the deal and they're sprinting
for the short run it's approach to the
missionaries who are paying attention to
the big idea
and understand it's a marathon in a
mercenary culture you obsess on the
competition
you may developed an aristocracy of the
founders the missionaries by contrast
focus on the customers and they build a
kind of cultural meritocracy where the
best ideas can win those mercenary
cultures tend to focus on financial
statements and the way they develop the
people is kind of loners kind of you're
on your own in the missionary culture
you'll hear a lot more about value
statements and people really try to
practice those and live those those are
companies that are infused with coaches
and they understand that it takes teams
to win in the mercenary culture you're
entitled to that additional bonus from
your large enterprise software company
as opposed to you've made a contribution
and now you'd be rewarded for it it's a
difference for joining what I like to
call the deferred life plan or the whole
life that really works anybody tells you
they're not interested in making money I
think is not telling you the truth
so there's between a lust for making
money or yes making money and also
meaning I think like they characterize
it as the difference between striving
for success or success in significance I
want emphasize again either these two
cultures can work I know there's one
that I prefer to be involved in which is
that missionary culture but it's
something to think about I believe as
you look for where you're going to
invest the very important and precious
next years of your lives
historically kleiner perkins has been in
two businesses the information
technologies and the life sciences
technologies or as I like to call it the
bits and bytes in the bugs and drugs and
one of the third legs that we added to
the stool it's a big strategic move for
us in the last five years is to spend
time with the green technologies the
inner Technic energy technologies the
biofuels and the batteries the solar
solar cells the wind and it's quite a
diverse industry it's been fun to learn
about that industry and to try to rise
to meet the challenges that we see the
main thing I want to say and orienting
you about
the green or the energy industry is it's
an enormous industry and if you want to
learn about it I encourage you to start
with this slide and then get al gore's
latest plug this slide shows the energy
flows the US economy the sources that
are on the left the uses are yes are on
your right for someone who's interested
in green as I am it's notable that
renewable resources account for less
than 6% of our energy sources among
those wind is the largest through this
diagram flows about I guess I guess
about a half trillion dollars a year of
purchases of oil from places that are
not particularly friendly to us the
petroleum expenditures and another
notable thing is through these energy
flows almost half the US energy is
wasted in the form of heat or
inefficient engines or transmission
lines so there's tremendous
opportunities to improve this energy
system lower its cost and have it be
renewable it's a very large market we've
been working in it actually seven years
that we didn't know that when we started
it's been five years that we've been
knowingly making investments in the
field we invested in a little over 50
companies and 600 million dollars
perhaps and more to come we're very
excited about those opportunities for
those of you who care about leadership
in the US and economic leadership the
contrast between green and digital or
the Internet is pretty profound what
Microsoft and Apple and Google and and
Netscape embarrass sign in eBay and
Amazon all have in common all those
companies are leaders in the Internet
industry worldwide and they're all
American if you look at where America
stands today in the green technologies
and and just pick the top 30 companies
10 each in wind in solar in vein
as batteries of those thirty only four
are American
only four so so we are almost not in
this race one of the top ten battery
companies one of the top ten wind
companies and two of the top solar
companies that should give us pause the
reason for that is we haven't had the
right policies to develop local markets
we haven't had the right level of
investment in R&D and so these are
things that we all as citizens and
people who care about innovation and
economic leadership in our country
autumn ought to be calling for writing
op-eds about talking to our senators and
political leaders so if we do that and
if we get it right we can ensure that
our country is a worldwide leader in
this next great global industry and if
we don't we're gonna be buying our wind
turbines from China borrowing money from
China to buy oil in the Middle East and
then to burn it in the middle of our
countries so there's there's a lot at
stake and I think the next five to ten
years are very critical but a policy is
not the business at Kleiner Perkins it's
it's innovation and backing
entrepreneurs to build great new things
and and so I'd like trade to give us an
overview of all the areas in which we're
making green investments and I'm gonna
ask GUI to do the same thing for our
digital portfolio thanks John
so as you can see we've actually been
incredibly busy over the last seven
years as John indicated we have over 50
companies that we would now classify as
green tech investments at KP one thing
that I think differentiates how we
invest from some other venture firms in
this area is that we haven't gone after
simply the companies that look like
information technology companies as
applied to green but we've really looked
at the whole spectrum everything from
supply side those are the big renewables
to efficiency companies to
transportation and so I'm gonna
highlight a few of the companies in our
portfolio and please if you have any
specific questions about any one of
these companies you know we're gonna
have a big Q&A session and feel free to
ask us some more details
as John pointed out you know we're less
than 6% of all of our energy comes from
renewables so we saw a huge opportunity
to ramp that up and we also saw a lot of
entrepreneurs we're coming to us with
really deep fundamental innovations in
this area as you can see we have a lot
of stealth solar companies a lot of
times in our early technology companies
we don't like to be very explicit about
what technology we're developing but we
have several companies that are focused
on next generation high efficiency lower
cost solar we have large-scale solar
through solar thermal companies we're
investing in geothermal we're investing
in in fuel cells so we have a very nice
portfolio on the supply side that is
really atypical for venture but again
like we said it's a really big leverage
point for energy economy going forward
we've also spent a lot of time in
renewable fuels and you can see that we
have quite quite a few fuels portfolios
now this is a sector that's gotten a lot
of negative press lately for people
who've gone after corn ethanol and
basically taking food and trying to
convert it to fuel we've stayed away
from that from the most part and are
really focused on the garbage part of
the you know rather than taking the the
fruits we're taking the parts that would
otherwise be burnt or destroyed or you
know people haven't been able to convert
into other useful things so we have
looked at every possible way chemical
processes physical processes to convert
that cellulose not into not only into
fuels but also into useful chemical
precursors so so we see a lot of
exciting innovation and activity going
on in this area despite what you may be
hearing from the market and the press
energy efficiency is really a catch-all
for a lot of technologies that are on
but what we call the demand side of the
market it's how you use the energy and
this is really about smarter energy
usage making processes that are less
energy intensive and and so this is a
broad broad range of companies but
there's one company in here I'd like to
point out because it's really it's part
of a whole ecosystem of companies that
we're all hearing a lot more about these
days and that's called the smart grid
and if you look around and you look at
all the networks that exist around us
you know the electric grid is one of the
dumbest there is out there it was
invented a hundred years
and really has not been updated since
and the best way to describe Silver
Spring is it's really overlaying the
Internet
on top of the electric grid you may have
heard this but you know if the
electricity goes out at your house right
now the only way that the utility
company knows about it is if you call
them up and tell them it's a really
truly dumb grid and technology like
Silver Springs what that means by laying
the internet over the top of it you're
essentially creating two-way
communication points between all the
nodes on the grid so now you start to
enable whole sets of ecosystems of
technologies that no one has ever been
able to think about before we're at the
very very early stages of that and our
portfolio company Silver Spring is one
of the big leaders in this area and PG&E
is one of their big partners and you may
have heard but we just recently rolled
out the one millionth node on the Silver
Spring Network in the Bay Area so
there's actually some incredibly
exciting stuff going on in the smart
grid the last area that I want to point
out today in our green portfolio is
really transportation and storage you
know a lot of people talk about
batteries being you know a key
innovation piece for not only renewables
performing better but for for
transportation batteries are incredibly
important so this is an area where we
have several stealth companies that are
innovating on new chemistry's better
efficiencies that we think over time
we'll be able to make electric vehicles
renewables on the grid far more usable
because we have appropriate and
cost-effective storage techniques the
last company I just wanted to highlight
is one that I spend a lot of time on it
and know well is in the transportation
sector and that's the Fisker you may
have heard a little bit about what
they're doing but the timing of
investing in a company like that is
actually pretty extraordinary right now
if you think about the automotive
industry and it's existed since the late
1800s not a ton of innovation and so for
the first time you've got this whole
electrification of the drivetrain big
technology shift happening and if you
look at other industries historically
this technology those major technology
shifts don't normally come from the big
incumbents so we've got this opportunity
for
new companies who are focused on this
new technology to come in and meanwhile
the big companies are fighting with
insolvency and lots of other just
macroeconomic issues so it really is an
extraordinary time to be investing in
the electrification of the drivetrain
that's exactly what we're doing with a
company like Fisker and so that's a
quick snapshot and with that I'll hand
it back over to John thanks very much
trade you know you might get the sense
that all kleiner is doing is green and
the truth of the matter is is that our
efforts in digital investing are just as
big and and have been longer lived than
the work that we're doing in green I'm
gonna fly through a similar overview of
the areas in which we're investing and
then we're gonna dive right into the
iPhone and the iPhone for the longest
time consumer facing businesses have
been explosive in terms of their growth
and and we continue to I believe be a
leader in in that field the most
exciting of all these investments is a
company called Zynga because anybody in
this room played farmville or cafe bill
or those games scramble Texas Hold'em
where there's 70 million people who are
playing Zynga games every month which is
just a remarkably large population and I
think they found a way to monetize to
get value out of the social networks and
that's by allowing people to buy virtual
goods it's quite a rapidly growing
company in fact the fastest I've ever
seen we're going to come to the I fund
in just a moment we're seeing a real
resurgence of interest in innovation in
the semiconductor fields in the science
of the small innovative new storage new
immense kinds of devices and then for
quite a while we've been investing in
digital infrastructure and innovations
there it was June 27th of 2007 right
when Apple shipped the first iPhones I
think I've got that right
and we were blown away at kleiner Bill
joy had been forecasting that this kind
of a device which could be in your
pocket know who you are where you are be
broadband always connected was an
enormous new platform so out of
strategic work that Gy
and Matt Murphy and Trey and I had done
we said this is going to be the next big
thing we want to go do a deal with Apple
and partner with them to encourage the
development those applications and we
did and we announced that in March of
last year and chi-wah named the iPhone
dealt with the 3,000 or more plans that
came in and so I'd like him to give you
a quick but really privileged glimpse
into what's going on with the
development of applications for these
new mobile devices great thanks John
so why did we launch the iPhone we saw
several trends of all being
simultaneously that got us really
excited
first of all wireless broadband
everywhere directly into your pocket
secondly a company like Apple that had a
real consumer brand and was expert at
developing great consumer products
coming into this market that had
historically been done by handset OMS
that didn't have good consumer
experiences a piece of hardware the
iPhone that was fundamentally a
computing device first and a phone
second app store which sits on 150
million desktops via iTunes and can
deliver new forms of software directly
to consumers with no intermediaries and
finally a software development kit that
would enable people developers many of
them who are in small to three-person
companies to develop desktop like
software that had historically been
impossible on mobile devices so what we
had was we had a computing device in
your pocket that was broadband connected
it was personal it was social it was
context aware and it could enable it an
entirely new class of applications and
this gives you a sense of what that
really means so to put it in raw terms
how many of you guys own an iPod that's
a lot of people so the iPhone is
outselling the iPod over its
two-and-a-half year launch period by a
factor of 12 twelve times as many
iPhones have been sold as iPods and you
saw how many people own iPods in its
two-and-a-half year launch period how
many of you guys have downloaded a song
on iTunes okay
App Store is outselling iTunes over its
two-year launch period by 20 times 2
billion applications have been
downloaded on the App Store in its first
eight quarters in that same that same
period of time in iTunes history only
had a hundred million songs downloaded
putting it in more simple terms for
something that you guys are now the Gees
that you guys would be familiar with
merrymaker put this slide together
recently and it showed what's happening
with the iPhone which is on the far left
iPhone iPod Touch is a consistent
platform compared to things we know like
Netscape 5 times as large as Netscape
yeah well 8 times as large as AOL and
mode in Japan which is as was previously
the most successful mobile platform
twice as big as m-mode nine quarters
after launch so what does that mean for
us it suggests that there's an entirely
new class of applications we've invested
in nine companies so far and we're going
after super verticals in those nine in
in that area of mobile going after
advertising commerce real time content
creation communication and
location-based services we think that
there will be a significant revolution
in the way that people access
information which is what this is really
about when it becomes mobilized and it
becomes real-time and we're looking to
invest in many more companies in that
area let's wrap up I'm making these
unsolicited career observations for you
and I realized that some of you are in
various phases of your career so you can
tune out anything that doesn't doesn't
feel right to you I think as you're
making the important choice about what
you're going to do when you leave the
graduate school I prioritized learning
and pick your first your next assignment
based on your ability to learn and grow
not so much on your level of
compensation now if you're among the
rare Stanford grads are almost grads you
dropout the way Larry and Sergey did I
want you to come see us right after this
conversation but I think for the vast
majority of us certainly for me I wanted
to go work in a place I'd learn a lot
which turned out at that moment in time
to be Intel I think developing a strong
foundation of experiences and commercial
experiences not just finance not just
control but selling yeah building a
business carrying a bag watching a
product managing people is a really
important skill to develop I think you
should try to learn really good
management and leadership processes from
some of the best companies because there
are some really great people to learn
from in the amazons yes the Intel's to
this day the end to its that Google is
even the GES there will come a time I
think in your career where you're going
to break that path and you're gonna go
off and really swing for the stands and
own or build your own business or build
one with others that's not true for all
of us but for many of us what I want to
suggest to you is you'll know when that
time is right
you don't need to do it right out of the
business school and indeed you can learn
a lot from others on their ticket and on
their own money whatever path you take I
believe you're going to be judged on the
following your ability to listen
actively think critically and above
everything else to communicate I think
you're judged by your ability to speak
on your feet to debate the merits of
issues and that's whether you're in a
large group or in a small group it's for
a very fundamental reason we believe
ideas are easy execution is everything
and in anything worth doing it takes a
team to win ideas are easy executions
everything it takes a team to win the
way you as leaders are going to inspire
teams is by your ability to think and
speak on your feet and rally others to
go after that cause that that set of
priorities that that business objective
one thing Andy Grove taught at Intel was
how important it is to be able to
confront a problem without confronting a
person so chi-wai it's not because
you're a jerk because you're not you
know it's this problem that we have with
the backlog of I fund applications that
are coming in we've got to figure out a
way to solve that business problem
together and so that that skill which I
don't possess well enough of confronting
a problem without confronting the person
is an essential one in leading groups so
I want to really encourage you to not
forego opera
Unity's to learn how to recruit to sell
to hire and fire to inspire to manage to
develop and motivate people with tough
love because whatever field you work in
I think it's a very fundamental skill
and then finally there's always extra
points for humor I sure wish I had a
better sense of humor and was something
of a stand-up comic I think quite to the
contrary the results of what I do are
what's kind of humorous extra points for
humor it's a very powerful social and
business weapon you're in the networking
business right here and now and you were
in the best place in the world to
network this is so much better than any
other place in the world and so I
encourage you to always network develop
and sustain personal and lifelong
networks and I don't mean the Facebook
kinds of networks I mean face-to-face
personal ones find a way when you're
networking so at every point in your
life sustain a mentorship relationship
with somebody find someone you admire
and say will you mentor me there's
nothing in it for them other than the
satisfaction of helping you but you in
turn can mentor someone else along your
way network like crazy look for
positions where there's a lot of
external contacts marketing sales
business development developer relations
be prepared to take risks to ask
permission is seek denial but all along
the way please remember that integrity
is a binary of state your integrity is
like sand you hold in your hands and if
you ever spread your fingers apart and
you let that sand fall through it it's
gone forever
integrity is a binary state either you
have it or you don't please
well so if it's not obvious I am
pregnant but I just wanted to say to you
can have a career and you can have a
family because I've seen a lot of my GSB
classmates drop out of the workforce as
life goes on and I just think that it's
important to know that it's not easy but
it can be done and so I just want to
throw that out there and there never is
a good time so I had my first kid when I
was launching a product and a startup
that I founded John was on our board it
was crazy it works out so I just want to
throw
don't put off having a family too late
I'm but that's a personal choice yep you
have anything to interrupt me about yeah
no not at the audition so this gig what
we're trying to do it's it's a marathon
it's not a sprint
one of the things I've done past times
I've been here as I've told you about
some of my favorite books I'll tell you
what if you send me an email with your
three favorite books I will send you
this list and of these my favorite at
the moment is called our choice it's Al
Gore's blockbuster book about the
solutions to climate crisis not the
problems so if you want to work at a
start-up or if you got a business plan
you'd like to get funded or you'd like
to work with us on a 380 project at
least they were called that please email
me or chi-wah or tray that the addresses
you see there and on that note I think
we're going to move into the QA part of
our conversation and I'd like to get as
many questions answered as we possibly
can this is your time so what we're
going to do is take the questions at you
can turn off the projector now please
about three at a time we're going to
throw them up in the board get as many
on the board as we can and in it and
then try to answer them so here's the
way to handle a question if you'll put
your hand up in your name then I'm going
to write the question on the board and
the questions are all in one deep breath
and they end with a question mark yes
you guys should sit here go ahead see
Brendan yeah questions are fine let's go
oh it's gonna be enough right yeah for
those of you didn't see it are we going
to avoid you catastrophic irreversible
climate crisis okay what are what are
the traits that we see among the
partners let's go with another question
please
entrepreneurs yes he's got a question oh
yes ma'am I was wondering I said most of
the power generation companies in clean
tech are Sodor
what do you think about the other power
gen other than solar ok great question
how about another one okay there was a
question about Android keep going trade
you want to feel the question yeah hi
Pablo
what what's the one piece of advice you
give someone starting a company today
okay start company advice Mike what are
the traits that you see that are
successful among the entrepreneurs that
really hit a winning traits
okay page for context okay
this is a venture capital grid culture
okay life questions over here raising
money at school for a charity for where
your your tuition all right that's a
venture capital really social
entrepreneurs
first you worry about the intensity of
business and second what do you see as
the monetization model for I write the
answer the first questions yes
ah how dollars for greentech okay
I'm gonna get two more try me names
Abhishek wondering what's the biggest
mistake you've ever made and how did you
overcome it okay that's a life mistake
metric as cares about trends in the
venture capital space and what kleiner
perkins is doing in response event okay
so this is great you know in about five
minutes we threw up there fifteen
questions I'm really impressed by our
efficiency and we'll figure it will take
ten minutes to answer a 15 question we
won't get them all and now we might even
give us some time for some more sand
follow-up ones and I think I'll just
take them in the order that we put here
on the board I gave a talk at Ted where
I got choked up at the end saying that
the engineering me didn't think we were
going to be able to avert catastrophic
climate crisis fundamentally because the
speed and scale at which we must act to
solve these problems and I think now we
will have enough innovation to solve the
part of the problem that is in the 10 to
20 year time horizon but if that's all
we do we will not avert catastrophic
climate crisis so most importantly we've
got to get some key policies right right
now if we've got to get them right
before we go to the midterm elections
and if we don't if we don't put a price
on carbon a price in a cap on carbon I
think by the end of the next set of
elections the United States will not
have the political power to do it the
United States doesn't lead the world is
not going to follow and we could be set
back five or ten years in the most
important leg of this so I'm not sure
it's enough yet stay tuned it really
matters power generation other than
solar we're very long on solar more so
than any other venture capital fund I
believe but we also think there are
equally exciting ways to generate
electricity and I would say solar
thermal is one of those there is a wind
as a way to generate electricity we
think we found a breakthrough in wind
and what other one I spent a lot of time
on in fact that's one where we read an
early study that said you know
a sector where you've got a base load
renewable the base load means it's
producing energy all the time regardless
of whether the sun is shining or the
wind is blowing and that it was
underfunded but that over the next you
know 25 years we could have 100,000
megawatts of produced geothermal if we
invested in it so we sought out the best
team and we actually did actually seed
fund a firm right now that just received
a twenty six million dollar grant from
the DOA and it's doing some of the most
innovative work in geothermal I didn't
know they got that yeah they did great
has incubated this company it's really
spectacular work by her I want to say
again in the form of career advice trade
could not have done that
if she were not an entrepreneur before
she came to kleiner and she didn't have
that authoring experience so that's a
great career role model how are we gonna
get the money that we need for green
tech well charity begins at home so the
first thing that we did is we raised a
billion dollar focused green tech fund
biggest funds kleiner has ever raised in
addition to devoting about 40 percent of
our ordinary startup venture capital
dollars to it but that's not enough we
took a look at how much capital our
current green ventures are going to need
the 50 or so ventures
it's another four and a half billion
dollars so we actively syndicate those
investments with other venture investors
and God bless the Obama administration
in the US government because we've
really got the a-team now working on
green innovation in our country and many
of these companies have applied for some
have made it some of not loan guarantees
from the Department of Energy I think
we're gonna be a little fund these
companies but I'm hoping for in fact I'm
expecting a really robust market for
public offerings in green starting next
year the next set of questions had to do
with venture capital firms and someone
astutely noted that if you look at the
at the photos of the kleiner partners
there's a great deal of diversity in our
partnership and you're not going to find
that in any other venture capital
partnership I assure you most VCS or a
half dozen to a dozen white male
Wonderbread you know
MBAs frankly some of whom have operating
experience some of whom do not and our
experience in building companies did you
just do not make good decisions that way
you do not deliver high service levels
you you want a diversity of ideas and
perspectives I think a third of our
partners are not Caucasian we have three
partners who are in the u.s. who are
fluent in Chinese we've got a team in
Shanghai led by Tina Zhu yeah and so
diversity is highly valued at kleiner
and in the companies we work on and in
the boards of those companies what are
the winning traits for entrepreneurs
Chee Hwa
what are you seeing great entrepreneurs
create entrepreneurs have a huge idea
and they can motivate a large group of
people to go pursue that with them
that's fundamentally the most important
thing that they bring they also bring
great judgment because many of them
oftentimes are young so they have
judgment above and beyond their
experience and that's something that is
not only learned but is oftentimes
intuitive tre where do you in that I
would say great entrepreneurs are
oftentimes great leaders they're ones
who can really inspire others to jump on
their mission because you know when
you're dealing in the early stages of
these startup companies it's a lot more
than just the amount of dollars you're
making from a salary that's motivating
you to do this because you're probably
not making a whole lot in the early days
and so you have to really have that
vision and be able to inspire others to
follow Marc Zynga who's the CEOs
markeson Zynga Mark Pincus who's CEO of
Zynga gave a talk that I think you can
find online at the startup school I was
really struck by it because he said to a
bunch of overwhelmingly white male geeks
listen you know let me tell you what the
gig is the venture capitalists they'll
back you and then as soon as they do
they want to replace you they want to
get serious professional management in
there before you know it you've lost
control of your company you were
negotiating for the wrong things you
negotiate it for valuation you should
have gone for control but he said more
than anything else you should try to
figure out if you can be and become a
CEO he said you ought to try to run that
business and you ought to be honest with
yourself to figure out what it's going
to take for you to develop those skills
and I'd say the best entrepreneurs
the ones that really go the distance
with their companies are always learning
they don't know what they don't know so
they attempt to do the impossible they
often do but if you look at Jeff Bezos
of amazon.com and you look at Larry and
Sergey yeah a unique thing they did at
Google bringing in Eric Schmidt these
leaders these entrepreneurs really try
to go the distance winning traits and
entrepreneur's we did we spent a little
too much time on Kleiner's culture how
do we make decisions it's a pretty
collaborative culture it's yeah there's
a lot borrowed from Intel in the culture
you want an environment where everybody
can put their ideas on the table so that
the best idea gets there and has a
chance to win will disagree but after we
make a decision we'll commit any
individual partner can veto an
investment trait can veto an investment
I can jiwa can it doesn't happen very
often because we build consensus along
the way for investment decisions what
else would you say about the culture I
would add that I think we also work in
teams a lot more than other venture
firms just having insight into how some
other firms work where it very much is a
lone wolf who goes out finds you know
his own investment and works on it
himself we're we oftentimes have a
couple of partners the other person can
call the other partners oftentimes you
tend to go native on a company and and
it's good to have that balance of vision
on what's actually going on and so I
would say that's something that really
differentiates KP G why you've been
another venture firm what would you yeah
I think the unique model that KP brings
to the venture capital firm is that
multiple partners are involved in every
single venture so as opposed to being
single threaded and getting one point of
view you're gonna get multiple point of
views and each of those are going to
come through different sets of
experiences which should help the
entrepreneur make better decisions
there's a topic here about investing in
social entrepreneurs I think it's a
really important thing to do
you can back social entrepreneurs three
ways you can back them with money if you
have the money with which to do that you
can back them with time and you can also
back them with reputation connections or
networking and every one of the kleiner
partners spend some out of their time
giving back some
republic ways others in private ways
it's one of our our strongly held values
we could talk a whole lot more about
that we could have a whole session on
social entrepreneurs there's a graduate
of the school Kim Smith who wrote a GSB
380 plan and founded something called
the newschools venture fund which
because of her work today has started
not forty five schools but forty twenty
five networks of charter public schools
that are allowing a hundred thousand
kids now in total to in really under
underserved poor areas to get far better
education as for venture capital in
emerging markets I don't know very much
about that we backed a team have built a
team in China they make their own
investment decisions we collaborate with
them on those but business in China is
very different than the rest of the
world we do invest in India we do invest
in in Europe but we do it out of Menlo
Park so it's very select when will make
an organization and investment outside
this area the predominant trends in
venture capital is that the industry is
shrinking and it needs to because the
returns have been lousy since 2000 take
the industry overall it's a loser if you
put money in the venture capital
industry you'll lose your money so we've
had too many venture capitalists chasing
too few really good ideas funding
incrementally undifferentiated socially
networked anonymous chat sites so that
you can get laid as you're walking down
University Avenue
I don't know what more to say about it
than that that's certainly not what our
priority is at Kleiner we'd rather help
entrepreneurs and build really
successful significant companies you're
gonna make a difference I probably got
enough trouble on that Android chi-wah
yeah so Android is the second dominant
platform we're watching it very closely
by the end of this year that'll probably
be between 10 and 20 million Android
devices out there for those of you that
don't know Android is an open source
operating system focused on mobile
devices that Google is created while
iPhone is a closed source operating
system that they control end to end the
issue with Android that we're all gonna
have to watch very closely if you guys
are thinking of doing developing on
Android today is fragmentation of the
ecosystem when you have open source and
you give it to a bunch of hardware OMS
each of them do different things with it
they've got different screen sizes
different keyboard layouts some have
keyboards some don't some go horizontal
some go vertical some leave GPS turned
on as default some don't so as an
application developer what killed the
mobile ecosystem over the last 10 years
in applications was the expense
associated with porting to hundreds
maybe thousands of different devices for
Android to be successful and we hope
that is as part of this trend in open
mobile it has to avoid that fate I think
I probably didn't do justice to trends
in venture capital I kind of got off
with the industry is a lot tougher
it takes more money to start ventures
now than it did before it takes more
time to get them to be developed
therefore I think it's fair to assume
that the that the returns are going to
be lower for the industry but what
offsets that are the outliers you know
they're most of the money in venture
capital has been made by firms in the
top decile the top 10% and and in the
industry even those have to perform
better than they have in the past there
is a trend towards green in the industry
that's the most rapidly growing sector I
think it's now number 2 or number 3 to
your question about the life sciences
that remains an incredibly important and
vibrant part of what Kleiner's doing
I don't really know enough about it to
give you a very good perspective on it
but we have a half-dozen partners who
are the best they do that day in and day
out
kleiner is not a quantity shop we're not
into the volume of investments or making
money on the fees from the investment
we'd rather be quality and and back a
smaller number of ventures to be more
involved in trying to help those there's
another important trend in metric
capital which is the rise of the angel
funds and that's particularly been
encouraged by virtue of the fact that it
takes less money now to start an
internet company by a factor of five or
so than it did 10 years ago we've
covered Android the advice to startup
companies if you googled John doors
startup manual there there's a nice
interview that was done in Fast Company
with me on exactly that point any
readers I think we've just scratched the
surface of what's possible I'm on the
board at Amazon and one a note that
amazon has said publicly when a book is
available on the Kindle or available in
the Amazon bookstore and they they are
the world's largest bookseller thirty
thirty five percent of the book sales
are through the Kindle and it's been out
for a little over a year that's an
astonishing shift so I think physical
books are not going away
but the e-readers I believe are going to
be here to stay in even in a world where
we may see tablets from Apple and others
this dedicated purpose-built device I
think I'll stick around I'm gonna skip
pay for content we just don't have time
Silicon Valley for digital startups I
believe it is the pace place still to do
a digital startup of course not because
of the latitude or the longitude but
because of the quality of the people
that are around here and you're in an
incredibly privileged place here at the
Business School one more piece of advice
don't take all your courses in the
business school figure out a way to get
into those other schools at this great
university hang around I don't know if
they're still in Margaret Jack's Hall
hang around the engineering school hang
around the innovations in energy and in
the life sciences because having taken
one more or less whatever your course is
accounting marketing whatever it is is
not so important I think is is reaching
out and connecting with innovation
that's going on
when I did a business school degree at
Harvard I took all my independent study
courses at MIT one in semiconductor
physics one in speech understanding one
was an independent study so you're in a
very privileged place right here and you
should take advantage of it
tactical strategy for work-life balance
I'm gonna give you mine and they have
tray and Chia I give you theirs what I
found the most important thing is for
somebody who wants to raise a family and
you may be a ways away from that
probably is how many times you get home
for dinner with your kids and then that
you be there while you're there for
dinner so I said fine I'm gonna set a
goal yeah it came from Intel if you
don't measure it doesn't matter
29:20 nights a month I'm gonna be home
by 6:30 to have dinner with my two
daughters and my wife and I'm not
disciplined enough to do that so Angela
helps me do it but we measure it and and
I've been achieving that ever since I
put it in as a goal but one other things
so that you're really there is is I have
everybody in our family
check our iPhones and stay off the web
for an hour before dinner and an hour
after we declare that to be a family
friendly internet free time zone okay so
first of all I'd say that there is no
such thing as work/life balance it
always feels a little crazy and hectic
and so the idea of you're gonna have
serenity and balancing the two is just
non-existent I think the thing that I've
learned is it does require extreme
prioritization and focus on what matters
to you and so to that extent it's good
to write it down and focus on I am gonna
be home at these times and I'm gonna do
my work at these times that I'm gonna go
exercise here and I'm gonna be really
anal and rigorous around planning this
otherwise everything else is going to
overtake my life and not let me do those
things when I get home and I try and be
home you know three of the five work
nights a week which doesn't always
happen but I try to I do not turn on my
computer or my iPhone until my kids are
in bed it's just it's a role I don't get
a lot of sleep during the week because
then after I put them in bed I'm up till
the wee hours of the night I'm getting
my work done but you know it's one of
the trade-offs I make and I feel with
that
balance I get - I get really good
quality time with my kids every night
and I you know I get my work done we
work really hard and and it all seems to
work out yeah I think one of the
critical things is to over communicate
and set very very clear goals so my wife
and I were married when we came to
business school and during that two-year
period believe in my class the class of
oh six there was eight couples married
couples who got divorced and for us that
was quite a shock to learn that and to
see that and what we learned through
that is to really communicate very
clearly and aggressively about how we
were doing with one another we have a
red light yellow light green light
methodology where yeah it's it's it's
really simple we can just check in with
each other and when she says things are
yellow I know that I have to slow down
and then the the other very clear goal
is if you set things that you need to do
every day make sure that you're there
and make sure that your partner's know
you need to do it so I have a
ten-month-old at home and one of the
things that I do with her every day is I
get home in time to give her her bath or
feed her dinner give her her bath and
put her to bed
and I've managed to do that almost every
single day in the last ten months
because I said clinicals I communicated
that to my partners they understood that
was a priority but they also understood
I've had other responsibilities that I
would take care of on behalf of the firm
I'm very proud of the culture at Kleiner
and so I'd like to share with you what
our values are because we screen for
these you know everybody at Kleiner
really I think likes being there and
respects the values of each other and
our our first priority is family first
right and so if anybody's got to do
anything to take care of their kid or
they're dying parent or my mom's got
brain cancer in a Taiwan I need to be
out of the office for half the time to
take care of her we just do that nothing
matters more than family and not
everybody's married and not everybody
has kids but you get the idea it can be
your extended family the second priority
is partners right so more important than
me trying to help Jeff Bezos is me
working with Trey or with Chia and vice
versa because ideas are easy executions
everything teams win and so we're very
much
that spectacular Lone Ranger can do it
all on their own there's really not room
for them in our partnership our third
priority is portfolio portfolio these
are the CEOs if you're not in the
venture capital business these are the
clients to whom you've already made
commitments we've got to serve them
every day that's more important than the
next new Facebook and so we prioritize
that the next priority is you ventures
new ventures
exactly tre is too busy with the first
three I got there more recently this is
the most seductive thing the new we're
innovation junkies we like spending a
lot of time with that you want to
prioritize it but it's clearly less
important than your family
and then the fifth priority is some form
of public or community service again in
the larger and the small interview no in
a private way because we've been given
so much it would be terrible if we don't
give back sometimes i wedge into this
list and notably not on it his friends
and if you want if you if you're as busy
as you are and we are and you want to
have friends you better prioritize it
you better invest time in it and I think
on that we're at our time limit five
minutes over and I'd like to thank all
you remember before before that if you
send us your three favorite books I'll
send you the list back that we had and
we'd love to talk about you with you
about the future thank you very much
[Applause]